do you date I do do you find that it's
difficult for young men mainly your age
group to find good women to date not at
all not at all not at all
um the women that you date and have
dated are they controlling how now I do
date women exclusively but how did you
know that I date women it's possible I
date men or both right well that is
possible but I wouldn't assume that
Obama didn't assume that yeah I'll let
you tell me do you date men too
exclusively women oh
would it be a bad thing for our
conversation if I dated men well I
wouldn't be bad for our conversation it
would be interesting okay all right why
don't you date men I'm not attracted to
men oh good
um I don't see anything wrong with it
but I know you do you do not see
anything wrong with it with being
attracted to men why not why why would
it be wrong uh because it's of the same
sex so it's abnormal
but that's not an argument